Russian military police say they have
started patrolling a rural area to the
west of the Syrian city of man beach
with a view to ensuring security their
broadcast Eve has more on the
development and how it's likely to ship
the ongoing power struggle in the region
this safe zone malla a buffer zone
really was established after Kurdish YPG
forces moved out they handed the area
over to the Syrian government the Syrian
army and it was declared a demilitarized
zone patrolled by Russian military
police monitors who arrived on the 7th
of January now the Kurds weren't acting
out of altruism but because turkey was
and is threatening to invade it used the
YPG and the PKK is terrorists between
the turkeys targeting Kurds is
irrational Turkish target is - and the
Kurdistan Workers Party terror groups
one of the goals of Turkey's struggle
against the PKK and that Syrian
offshoots is to save the Kurds from the
tyranny and oppression of this terror
group Trump's declaration that he's
pulling out of Syria
certainly threw things into a state of
flux US allies the YPG who had lived
under and depended on American
protection suddenly face being left
alone with hostile Turks rebels Isis
Syrians on all sides their own Arab
allies ready to dump them reportedly and
US National Security Advisor John Bolton
is desperately trying to secure a future
safety for his Kurdish allies we're
gonna be discussing the president's
decision to withdraw but to do so from
northeast Syria in a way that makes sure
that defense of Israel and our other
friends in the region is absolutely
assured and to take care of those who
have fought with us against Isis and
other terrorist groups at the end of the
day the US will leave
the Kurds understand this obviously and
they're fast tracking negotiations with
President Assad with the Syrian
government could into various reports
reconciling perhaps obviously they have
their differences but it's a hostile
neighborhood friends are few and far
between and as we see now they can leave
at any moment
you